Yo.
>> Hello. Do you hear me? I'm doing well.
Okay.
I want to say so I'm a Muslim first off.
Secondly, what I want to argue about is
that we as Muslims follow Jesus better
than you do.
>> Okay.
>> Can I say Can I say right back to you?
>> It's
But yeah.
>> Yeah. Okay. So, the reason I said that
is so in Aramaic he says shalom. Okay.
>> Who?
>> Jesus.
>> Peace be on to you.
>> Where do you see him? Where do you see
him doing that?
>> In the in the B. Wait,
>> where in the Bible does he speak Aramaic
and say peace be unto you in Aramaic?
>> The Bible was re Well, we believe the
Bible was revealed in his language,
which is why because he spoke Aramaic.
Aramaic.
>> How do you know he spoke Aramaic? I'm
sorry.
>> Because he was uh born in Bethlehem,
right?
>> How do And how do you know that? That's
that's what Christians say that he was
born in Bethlehem.
>> So So the Christians are right when it
comes to Jesus. Is that is that right?
>> What I said what you say is that he was
born in Bethlehem and that he says peace
be on to you.
>> I got you. Are the Christians right?
>> That he was born in Bethlehem.
>> Yeah. About all the about everything
they say about Jesus. Born in Bethlehem,
spoke Aramaic. Cuz these you're getting
this stuff from us.
>> Yeah. I I believe because we also
believe that.
>> Okay. So, you're getting your
information about Jesus from us, but
you're trying to argue that you follow
Jesus.
>> I'm trying to I'm trying to tell you
that in the Bible, he says, "Peace be
with you or peace be onto you." Uh,
>> I
>> I know. I know what you're trying to
say.
>> This verse is John 20:21. Again, Jesus
said,
>> "Slow down, please.
>> Wait, that's not my name. It's my dad's
name."
>> Oh, it's in It's
>> in Arabic. It's what
>> you can just say. Yeah.
>> Gotcha. Say okay, cool. So say
>> Yeah.
>> You said that you Muslims follow Jesus
better than us Christians, right?
>> Well, I you ask for the verse where he
says, "Be peace be onto your beast be
with you." Right. I found John 21.
>> No, no, no, no.
>> Can I finish my point?
>> No. Say, I need you to listen so that
you understand where we're at in the
conversation, bro. Please. You said
>> go ahead. You said that Muslims follow
Jesus better than Christians. I asked
you why do you believe that?
>> You said because Jesus said peace be
upon you in Aramaic. Shalom.
I can't even I don't even Yeah.
>> Right. So I I challenged that. I said
where do you see Jesus ever saying peace
be upon you in Aramaic? And you're going
to the Bible and you're saying because
that's the language he spoke. And I
asked how do you know that he spoke
Aramaic? You said because he's from
Bethlehem. I asked, "How do you know
you're from Bethlehem?" And you said,
"Because that's what Christians say."
So,
>> well, I'm going with what you because if
I challenge what uh your belief, you're
going to keep asking where I'm getting
my information from.
>> This isn't about my belief. So, you
started with your belief. You said you
believe that Muslims follow Jesus better
than Christians. And this was your one
of your proofs.
>> Well, well, okay. Can I continue the
proof then?
>> Wait. So, so we can conclude where we're
at. So you're you're getting your
information about Jesus from Christians.
Is that right?
>> Well, it's if if I quoted the Quran, you
wouldn't you wouldn't believe it because
>> Does your Quran does your Quran tell you
Jesus was from Bethlehem and spoke
Aramaic?
>> Well, from he talked to Ben is
>> where were they?
>> Which are all over the place. How do you
know that Jesus was in
>> Go ahead.
>> Well, the ones near the Caucus'
mountains that he talks about that in
the Quran. talks about the caucuses
mountains
>> near it. You said they were all over the
place, right?
>> Yeah, they were all over the place.
>> Okay. Benny is as in uh which is modern
day Palestine. I don't know if you
believe that or not, but
>> brother Ben Israel. Ben Israel is not a
place.
>> The children of Israel.
>> Yeah, the children of Israel. He talked
to them. They were out in the
Palestinian area.
>> All right. Where does your Quran say
that?
>> Okay. Okay. Uh we're devoted to our
shies. M
>> put on.
>> We've only been live for 2 hours. Bro,
this is insane. What is happening,
>> bro? This is This is going way off
course. I was trying to say that only
Muslims say that he the same greeting
that he says. No Christian I've heard in
my life say peace be onto you. No. And
my second point was that you don't
prostrate like Jesus. You don't. No one.
No, I've never seen a Christian actually
prostrate toward God or for him. The you
don't worship the you don't follow the
Sabbath day, which is in your
commandments that the Sabbath day is
Saturday. Keep the Sabbath day holy, but
you it was changed because apparently
you wouldn't be you didn't want to be
likened to the Jews. Okay. So, we we
prostrate like him. We say peace be onto
you like him in in Arabic and
uh we he we didn't say he was cursed
like Paul did in the Bible because he
was cursed because he was hung on the
cross. Okay, that's why I'm trying
that's was going to be my point before
you started asking irrelevant questions.
>> Okay, awesome. So, prostrate like Jesus,
the peace greeting like Jesus, following
the Sabbath, observing the Sabbath day
like Jesus. Was there another one?
>> Well, we didn't we don't observe the
Sabbath day. I I brought that point up
because Christians don't
>> Oh, I thought you said you Okay, so
Sabbath day. What about What about being
baptized? Cuz Jesus was baptized, right?
>> Well, he was baptized because as a
Jewish tradition.
>> Yeah. Do you uh get baptized?
>> Well, no.
>> Okay. You don't get baptized. All right.
What about fasting for 40 days straight?
>> No, but we have Ramadan which is 30
days.
>> Yeah, but you guys eat during your fast.
>> You fast for Easter.
>> But you you guys eat during your fast,
right?
>> Yeah. Otherwise, we would die. Like
>> Jesus fasted for 40 days and 40 nights
and didn't die. He probably was very
skinny.
>> A miracle.
>> All right. So Jesus fast.
>> It's a miracle by God. That's a miracle.
We're not supposed to be able to do
miracles.
>> I got you, bro. I got you. I got you. I
got you. I got you. Um, so prostrate
like Jesus, say the peace greeting like
Jesus, observe the Sabbath day like
Jesus, baptized Jesus got baptized, fast
for 40 days like Jesus. And so, okay.
All right. So, we already got the
>> All right. So, you already do not fast
like Jesus. You don't get baptized. So,
you don't get baptized like Jesus. I'm
just going to mark off the things that
you guys don't do like Jesus.
>> Well, okay. Okay. We don't 40 days and
40 nights cuz they would kill us.
>> We don't fast on Jesus.
>> No one does that. But the Christians
don't even
>> peace greeting and prostrate. So this is
where we're at so far.
>> So all right. [clears throat] So let me
ask you this. Okay.
>> And and I also said that he was never
cursed in the Quran.
>> He was never cursed. That's okay. That's
awesome.
>> Yeah.
>> So All right. So let me uh let's let's
let's get down to the nitty-gritty now.
Okay. So all of these things you're
saying is true of Jesus. These are
things that we know for sure that he
did.
>> Yeah. According to your Bible.
>> Okay. So the Bible gives us the truth
about Jesus. Is that right?
>> Well, if if you're going to what's it
called? If you're going to not like
believe me if I brought other sources
other than the Bible and how am I going
to argue my point? Like if I said if I
took something from Quran and I said
it's true, you wouldn't believe it.
>> Well, that's why you'd have to prove
that. But my what I'm saying is that
you're giving me your belief right now.
You believe that you follow Jesus better
than Christians, which means you have a
standard of things Jesus did, truly did,
and you're comparing Muslims and
Christians to the standard that Jesus in
and what Jesus behaved and how he
practiced. So yes, when you name these
things off,
>> we're being sure that these are true
things that Jesus did, which then we can
make a correct comparison on whether or
not Muslims or Christians follow Jesus
the right way. Right?
>> Well, okay, I'll explain it better for
you. If according to your Bible, Jesus
did all of that, why don't Christians do
the same thing?
>> I know your argument. I need you to
answer the question so that we can lay
this foundation forward. argument.
You're trying to say that, "Oh, I
believe the Bible is true." I'm telling
you, I'm arguing through your Bible.
>> Is my Bible is my Bible telling me the
truth about Jesus?
>> If that's what you believe, then sure.
But
>> I don't care about what I believe,
brother. Remember, because according to
my belief, I follow Jesus better than
Muslims. But you would argue otherwise,
right? So, who cares about our belief?
>> No, no, hold on, say, I don't care about
your belief or my belief. I care about
objectivity. Okay? Regardless of what
you and I believe, what is the standard
and what what is upheld to that standard
or what what falls short of that
standard.
>> So when you gave me and I wrote it down,
you gave me the list of things. You gave
me the list of things that Jesus did.
You you brought these things up as if
these were true things, true actions of
what Jesus did from the Bible. So, I'm
asking did the is the Bible giving us
the truth about Jesus? Simple. Yes or
no? If
>> Well, uh, some of the thing is I I don't
know what like how to answer that
because if I said yes, you're going to
be like, well, it says he's the son of
God, blah blah blah. But the reason I
again, let me explain this in a in a way
that will help you understand why.
What's the other option?
>> The other option is that some of what
the Bible says is true and some of it
isn't. But that's what
>> get us anywhere.
>> This is this is another my friend, you
have fallen into another Islamic
dilemma.
>> Yeah. What is it?
>> You're saying that that the Bible is
telling us the truth about Jesus, which
would then mean you are affirming that
the Bible is true about Jesus.
>> According to the Bible, he said all that
stuff,
>> which means you have to affirm he's the
son of God and all these kind of things.
But then that goes against your Quran.
That would mean that your Quran is
false. If these things are true.
>> Well, my question is my question is why
don't you do why don't Christians do the
same thing?
>> That's secondary, brother. I need to
know if this is the truth about what
Jesus did so that we can examine your
what you're saying or not. Is the Bible
telling us the truth about Jesus? Yes or
no?
>> Sure. Yeah. If if you want if you
believe that the Bible says the truth
about Jesus.
>> No, it's not. See, there you go again.
There you go again. Say, you're not
you're not debating this honestly. You
brought these points up as facts about
Jesus, things he did, the way he
practiced his religion, and you got
these facts from the Bible, and you're
using these facts to say Muslims follow
Jesus more accurately than Christians
follow Jesus. So that means you're
saying that the Bible is giving us true
accurate information about Jesus, right?
>> Well, some of it, I guess. Yeah,
>> some of it. Okay. So, these things at
least these things right here.
>> Can we not everything?
>> Let's maybe say not everything, but at
least these things right here are are
truths about are true accurate facts
about Jesus that we can find in the
Bible. Is that right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, this is what I want you to do
for me. Let's deal with number one,
prostrating. Can you show me in the
Bible where Jesus prostrated? And let's
see if you prostrate like Jesus or if
Christians prostrate like Jesus.
>> Okay.
>> All right.
>> Oh, I spelled that wrong.
>> It's okay. Are you going to Matthew or
Mark or Luke or John?
>> The Matthew 26 39.
>> And what does it say?
>> Jesus falls with his face to the ground
and prays.
>> What does the verse say?
>> No, it doesn't it doesn't say that,
>> right?
Well, I'm just uh hold the leper came up
to him and prostrating himself worshiped
him. The leper touched him.
>> Matthew 26:39. Just read that verse.
What does that verse say?
>> What this says? Matthew 8. When I click
okay,
>> 26.
>> Just go to Matthew 26:39. It'll come up.
>> Matthew and I don't deal with all these
numbers. We just have and Oh, yeah.
Okay. I found it. Going a little
farther, he threw himself upon the
ground in his face and prayed, saying,
"My father, if it's possible, let this
go pass away from me." Nevertheless,
not. Yeah.
>> All right. Al, oh no, I lost him. He
should come back. He probably
accidentally clicked another tab. He'll
be back. Make sure you guys are hitting
the like button. Man, we almost got
4,000 people watching the stream, guys.
Make sure each and every one of y'all
hit the like button like you fear
disobedience from it, man. The the the
ministry really is growing, guys. We
actually we just hit uh what? We just
hit 450,000 subs. We just hit 450,000
subscribers. If you guys are new to the
channel, if you're new to the ministry,
please go ahead, subscribe. Uh, make
sure you hit the notification bell. You
will not want to miss any of these type
of live streams or any videos that we
got going on. Also, I got a video coming
out tomorrow for my discussions with uh
a Shia Muslim from Baloa Park yesterday.
All right, he's back.
>> Okay. Sorry, I clicked out by mistake.
>> It's okay. So, we got the verse in the
Bible that tells us that Jesus
prostrated. And the way that he
prostrated is that he prostrated, fell
down to this fa with his face to the
ground and prayed saying, "Father, if it
be possible, let this cup pass from me,
but not my will, let your will be done."
Do you prostrate and call Allah your
father?
>> No.
>> Nope. So, do you prostrate like Jesus?
>> Prostration as in the action? Yes.
>> No. the action
>> whatever he said whatever he said we
don't believe that's true
>> let me ask you this
>> believe said my father
>> let me ask you this if uh the pagans who
prostrate to to idols and statutes do
they do they prostrate like Muslims
>> well we're not talking about pagans
we're talking about Jesus
>> if if I prostrate to a statute do I
prostrate like a Muslim
>> no
>> good
>> we don't prostrate to statues
>> exactly so what you're prostrating to is
is And it matters when it comes to
>> pro to the father which is Allah.
>> Okay, good. So Allah is the father then.
Is that right?
>> Well according to your Bible where it
says that he's the father.
Believe that he's just Allah.
>> And remember we said that or you said
sorry you agreed and said that the Bible
>> is giving us facts about Jesus. These
things that we see in the Bible at least
these particular things the Bible got
accurately correct. It's factually true.
So in the way that Jesus prostrated, he
prostrated,
>> right? So who did Jesus prostrate to
according to this verse?
>> Well, Allah or Yahweh or whoever you
call him, Allah,
>> brother, brother, be honest with me.
Don't play this game.
>> Yeah, sure. The if you if you want to
say father, sure, but
>> if I want father, I don't like to do
that. I don't like to do the if if you
want to say or I like to deal with
absolutely.
>> Well, it says my father.
>> So, who is he prostrating to? Allah or
you.
>> So Allah is his father.
>> The father.
>> Is Allah the father?
>> Yes. In in in the Bible, Allah is the
father.
>> So So thank you. So Allah is the father
in the Bible. So Jesus is prostrating to
his father who is Allah. So do you agree
with that? That Jesus is the son of
Allah who he prostrates to.
>> No.
>> So do you prostrate like Jesus?
>> When we prostrate, we prostrate to
Allah.
>> Do you prostrate like Jesus? Do you
prostrate to the father who's in heaven?
>> If the father is Allah, then yes, we
prostrate like
>> I didn't say it. I'm not asking ify.
Let's do this one last time. Let's make
it clear so that you understand this
isn't
>> Well, you're stop talking, please. I
need you to understand it. Please slow
down cuz I I want you to get it. And I
think you do get it and you're playing
with me. So, I'm I'mma take it so that
you're playing with me. And hopefully
from this point forward, you can stop
playing with me. So, here we are. Okay.
>> All right.
According to the verse, Jesus prostrates
to his father. Correct? Yes or no?
>> To the verse. According to the verse.
Yes.
>> Okay. According to you, you said that
these examples that we get in the Bible,
it's given us true, accurate, factual
information about Jesus and what he did.
Right. You said that earlier, correct?
>> Some of it. Yes, that's what I said.
>> Right. So I asked you specifically these
things that you mentioned in the Bible
are true right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So in the Bible
>> they being said and okay
>> right so when the Bible mentions that
Jesus prostrated that verse is true.
It's giving accurate information of what
Jesus did. So when we see how Jesus
prostrated, when we see how Jesus
prostrated because who you prostrate to
is part of how you prostrate, you agreed
with that earlier, remember?
>> Yes.
>> Awesome. So according to the verse, how
Jesus prostrated was by prostrating to
his father, right?
>> He said the father.
>> So his father, right?
>> My father. Okay.
>> Yeah. My father.
>> Yeah. So he prostrated. How he
prostrated was by prostrating falling
down to the face to his father. Right.
>> In in the verse. Yes.
>> Right. Do you prostrate like Jesus?
Falling down to your face to your father
in heaven.
>> Well, my father you falling to your
father in heaven.
>> Do you prostrate? Do you fall down with
your face to the ground towards your
father in heaven?
>> No.
>> Thank you.
>> Not not to the father.
>> Right. So you
>> not not a father.
>> So I got you. Jesus. Okay. I'll tell you
something. I'll tell you something. In
in the Arabic Bible, it doesn't say my
father. It says Allah.
>> Yes, it does.
>> Are you sure?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Let's Let's see.
>> Pull it up. You read Arabic?
>> Yeah. I speak it fluently.
>> Oh, that's beautiful. That makes it even
better. Pull up Matthew 26 uh 39 Arabic
Bible. If you need help, I can I can
help you get it. Read it. Read it out
loud once you see it,
>> please. Out loud.
Yeah. Okay. So, he does say my my
father. Okay. Well,
>> so in in the Arabic, in the English, in
the Greek, in the Aramaic, no matter
what language you put it in, Spanish,
Hebrew,
>> we don't have an Aramaic Bible.
>> We do have an Arabic. We do have an
Aramaic Bible.
>> The The Bible was revealed as one book
in Aramaic. Those are just translations.
>> No, the Bible is multiple books, dude.
Please stop.
>> What? How is the Bible multiple books?
>> Do Do you know how many? That That's
besides
>> Well, I know how many there are.
Catholic things. There are 66.
>> No worries. No worries. Say, I need you
to focus.
>> 73.
>> So So Jesus prostrated to his father.
You said you don't prostrate to your
father. So here's the question. Be
honest with the question, please, or
else I'm going to have to move on to the
next person. But I want to continue
talking to you. So, please answer this
honestly. Do you, in light of what we
just saw, Jesus prostrates to his father
in heaven? You don't prostrate to your
father in heaven? Do you prostrate like
Jesus? Yes or no?
>> Well, no. Sure. Yeah. No, we don't
prostrate like him. If
>> if you're saying that the father is
saying the father I'm not saying
anything.
>> Well, I'm telling you that.
>> So, I could put an X is Allah. Yeah, we
it's literally the same. The Holy Spirit
is angel Jel and Jesus is a prophet.
That's
>> Can you show me where Jesus says? Can
you show me where Jesus says that?
>> Where he says what?
>> That that the G that Gabriel is the Holy
Spirit.
>> Oh, no. In the Quran.
>> Oh, I thought we were talking about
Jesus.
>> No, no, no. I'm I'm telling you the
comparison between our religions is when
it says the father, we're talking about
Allah.
>> No, you're not.
>> Okay.
>> That's not true.
>> Yes. No, it's not.
>> Yes, it is true.
>> Go to go to Okay. Go to chapter 5 verse
71 of your Quran. Let's see. Let's see
who the Christians say Allah is.
>> Who the the Christians? What? I said
that for us the father is Allah. I I
don't get what you just said.
>> That's not true. You just said Allah is
not the father. So stop saying for us
Allah is the father cuz he's not. You
just said he's not the father.
>> What Christians say is the father is
Allah for us. I didn't say Allah Allah
is not the father.
>> I didn't say Allah is not the father
without explaining.
>> You did. You said you know what? Let me
give you an an opportunity. We got 4,000
people watching this now. Let me give
you a a golden opportunity be to be
honest. Is Allah the father? Yes or no?
>> Well, it's not a yes or no question. If
I say no, if I say no, you're going to
say, "Oh, well then uh
>> don't worry about the Jesus." Brother,
don't worry. You already Dude, I don't
We're past that. You already said
>> you're adding a leading question.
>> Say,
you already acknowledged and conceded
that you don't pray like Jesus. So,
we're past that. I already put an X next
to that. I put an X next to prostrate. I
already put an X there.
>> So, you don't do that like Jesus. But
now, it seems like you're you're kind of
argu you're kind of wrestling with
whether or not is your father or not.
So, I'm giving you a golden opportunity
right now.
>> No, he isn't. I'm okay. If if something
if some if someone calls something like
what say uh
>> I'm trying to give an analogy or an
example like
>> I just want to know if Allah is the
father, bro. Yes or no?
>> Well, no. Thank you. So therefore, you
don't even father.
>> Guess what? Guess what?
>> You don't even believe like Jesus. You
don't pray like Jesus. You don't fast
like Jesus. You're not baptized like
Jesus. You don't observe the Sabbath
like Jesus did and you don't believe
like Jesus did. How in Allah's jennim
can you ever say that you fallen?
>> Bro, that is blasphemy to say that.
>> How can you How can you ever say no?
Hell belongs to Allah, right?
>> No. Saying that's in Allah's hell.
That's in God's hell. That's not That's
blasphemy.
>> That's his own Does he not own hell?
>> No. saying it saying it as like an
emphatic emphasis.
That's not Allah's hell. That's not his.
>> No, I'm saying it's blasphemy because
you're using as an emphasis. But that's
not that's beyond the point.
>> That don't make no sense,
>> bro. If you say that's using God's name
in vain.
>> How? How? That's not his name. Allah
doesn't have a name.
>> Oh, is it?
>> That's Allah. Yes. Allah means God and
he has 99 attributes. What's the name of
that god?
Allah just means God. What's his name
though?
>> Well, he he has 99 attributes for names
and one of those asking what is his
name?
>> I told you he has 99 names which are his
attributes.
>> Okay. So, he doesn't really have a name.
So, look,
>> which is Allah. Yeah, bro. You're
literally arguing about nothing.
>> Brother, I'll give it to you. All else
his name. So, in light of all of this,
>> you don't believe like Jesus. You don't
pray like Jesus. You don't fast like
him. You're not baptized like Jesus got
baptized and ordered for everyone to be
baptized. Um, how in the world can you
say that you follow Jesus better than us
when we prostrate to our father and we
pray to our father in heaven?
>> We observe the Sabbath day.
>> We get baptized.
>> I observe the Sabbath day on Sunday.
>> What are you talking about?
>> The Sabbath day is Saturday.
>> Sweetheart,
>> not Sunday.
>> Come here real quick. One second.
>> Yes.
>> Do you observe the Sabbath?
>> Yeah. On what day?
>> Saturday.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> Hi.
>> Why is church service on Sunday then?
>> Church service has nothing to do with
the Sabbath, dude. Church service is on
Sunday because Jesus rose on the first
day of the week, Sunday morning.
>> Okay. Okay. Wait a second. Okay.
According to bibleinfo.com,
most Christians observe the Sabbath day
on Sunday, Thursday of the week rather
than Saturday, which is traditionally
considered the Sabbath.
>> That's a lie.
>> How is that a lie?
>> Let me Let's Let's ask. Look, there's
4,000 people in here. 600 on um
Christians, do you guys think that
Sunday is the Sabbath? That Sunday when
you guys go to church that that's the
Sabbath. Let's see what the chat says.
>> Okay, how do I share my screen? It's
bibleinfo.com lying.
>> Yes, if that's what they're saying.
Every Christian in the chat is saying
no. Are you looking at the chat? Please,
dude, look at the chat.
>> I'm so confused.
>> Just look at the chat.
>> Okay, the comments.
>> You see the comments? You see how
they're saying no? No. No, no, no, no,
no, no. Hey, chat Christians,
>> what day is the Sabbath day for us
Christians? What day is the Sabbath
according to Christians?
>> I'm
>> Saturday.
>> Okay. Okay. I You're just switching it
up.
>> Switching it up.
>> Switching up like ad hoc. Yeah,
>> how why would you going to tell me what
I believe? You going to tell me
according to my religion?
>> Well, I'm not telling you what I
believe. I'm telling you your websites
and the and priests say that they
worship on Sunday on online.
>> Nobody said anything else about not we
do worship on Sunday. Nobody takes
Sunday as the Sabbath.
>> Oh my god. Christianity.com.
>> I is this is this like a fake website?
Am I don't do I not understand English?
>> What does it say?
>> Okay.
>> Does it say that Christians worship on
Sunday?
>> They say to observe the Sabbath day on
Sunday. Yeah, most Christians observe
the Sabbath day on Sunday.
>> Yeah, that's a lie. What? Whoever is
making this this claim is a lie. That's
a lie.
>> Can I share the screen? How do I share
the screen?
>> You can push present. I'm not saying
that. I don't disagree that uh I don't I
don't doubt that what you're looking at
is what you're reading. I'm saying that
what you're reading is a lie.
>> I can read that.
>> Why are they lying?
>> I don't know why people lie about
Christianity all the time on online
>> on a website called Christianity.com and
Bibleinfo.com.
Really lies.
>> Okay. You know what? Sure. If you if if
you're just gonna like claim that
they're all lying, all these authors,
all these people are lying, sure, I can
see I can see that because
>> I it'll do me no good to just to argue
against that.
>> Yeah. So, with that being said, how can
you ever say when you do not follow
observe the Sabbath, you do not believe
like Jesus believed that God is his
father in heaven? You don't believe
that. You don't believe like Jesus
believed. You're not baptized like Jesus
commanded to be baptized and he was
baptized. So, how in the world can you
say that you follow Jesus better than
us? You don't follow Jesus at all.
>> Well, this is this is kind of like
because the if I didn't use your Bible
again, if if I didn't cite your Bible,
you would not believe anything I I say.
>> Okay. You know what?
>> It says the father. Sure.
>> Guess what? Guess what? Scratch scratch
the Bible. see everything. Notice it
wasn't me that went to the Bible, it was
you. You went to the to the Bible for
facts about Jesus. And so now that we
see that you're as Muslims, you guys
don't even believe like Jesus. And so
therefore, you guys are in falsehood.
Let me go ahead and grant you your other
crutch. Forget the Bible. Forget the
Bible. Okay. What do you do like Jesus
better than us? Is it Do you still hold
to these lists? Prostrate, peace, peace
greeting, Sabbath day observance, being
baptized, and fast 40 days. You you you
still hold to these things you listed?
Well, I listed uh fast 40 days, but the
others prostration, peace, greeting,
Sabbath day. Do you hold to these still?
No Bible.
>> Well, well, I don't The Sabbath day
wasn't Maybe I didn't explain that
right, but Sabbath day wasn't something
we did. We do. Then why did you list
that Jesus does?
>> No, no, no. I brought it up because
>> because you got Yeah, we don't follow
it, but Christians are supposed to. Yet
they don't. Yeah, apparently now you're
saying Saturday is a Sabbath.
>> Aren't you a follower of Jesus? Aren't
you supposed to follow the Sabbath day,
too, then?
>> Well, we our worship is is daily. It's
not a Sabbath.
>> So is the Christians. Matter of fact,
>> you don't have five prayers a day. Al
also didn't Jesus didn't Jesus worship
every day?
>> Well, do you have uniform prayers?
>> Can you can you answer the question? Did
Jesus worship God every day?
>> Yeah, he did.
>> But yet he still observed the Sabbath
>> as a Jewish tradition. Yes.
>> Okay. So Jesus observed the Sabbath even
though he worshiped every day. Why don't
you observe the Sabbath if you're a
follower of Jesus?
>> I we don't observe the Sabbath because
it it's literally like it's not even in
listed in the Quran. And it's not
mentioned.
>> Yes, it is. It is listed in the Quran.
Matter of fact,
>> no, it's not listed as something that
Muslims are have to do.
>> Wait, what do you mean? Why? What do you
mean Muslims don't have to do it? Jesus
did it. What do you mean Muslims? Do you
have a different religion than Jesus?
>> No. I Maybe maybe I'm missing something.
Maybe he didn't even say Okay, maybe he
didn't even observe the Sabbath day in
Islam.
>> Jesus, let let me let me let me search
it up. What? You're saying that Jesus
broke the Sabbath in Islam?
>> Wait a second.
>> Let me let me let me write that down,
man. Well, you're saying maybe. So, I
won't I won't mark it down as a for sure
claim just yet. But if you if you saying
that, you going in the red book, bro.
>> No. No. It's be it's because like I
don't know. I maybe I'm not qualified to
like have an argument about this cuz I
don't know if even in Islam we think
that Jesus observed the Sabbath day or
not. If if he did in Islam in the Quran
because our our holy day is Friday. It's
not really a Sabbath. But
>> then how do you know Jesus observed the
Sabbath?
>> How do you know that Jesus observed the
>> I'm making a guess since he was brought
up as Jewish.
>> But I don't care about your guesses. I I
care about what Jesus actually did, bro.
So, did Jesus observe the Sabbath or
not? And if so, how do you know? If not,
how do you know? I
>> I then I don't know if he did or not.
>> Okay.
>> Well, it's according to the Bible that
he WOULD [screaming]
>> OKAY. Are you okay?
>> No Bible. Remember, no Bible. You're not
allowed. Bibles off the table. Remember?
Okay. So, we don't know. Since you're
using the Quran, we don't know if Jesus
observed the Sabbath. All right, forget
that. Forget the Sabbath. Prostration.
How do you know Jesus prostrated?
>> Uh,
okay. Let me let me use the Quran then.
>> Yeah, use the Quran. How do you know
Jesus prostrated?
>> Okay. Uh, in it's there's a verse that
he says, I'll say it in English. Quran
19:30
to34. Indeed, I am the servant of Allah.
He's giving me the scripture and made me
a prophet. Has made me blessed wherever
I may be and has enjoyed me upon prayer
and zaka as long as I remain alive. May
be beautiful to my mother and did not
make her a wretched tyrant. Peace on me
the day I was born and the day I die.
>> The day I embraced alive. Okay. Doesn't
say prostrate, but he
>> It does say he prayed, but it doesn't
tell you how he prayed, right?
>> I don't believe so. I I don't I don't
know what verses to find cuz like I'm
trying to look
>> I'll help you
>> on surah
>> No, I can help you.
>> Yeah.
>> Would you like to know where it is in
the Quran?
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> All right. It doesn't exist.
>> Okay.
>> It's not there.
>> Jesus observing the Sabbath day. Not
there. Jesus prostrating not there. So,
how do you know Jesus prostrated then?
Cuz the Quran doesn't tell you.
>> Okay. Uh,
I'm just doing Take your time.
>> I guess I don't know. But
>> say it again.
>> I guess there's no definitive evidence.
>> H.
>> So then why did you say that Jesus
prostrated? Like it was definitive
evidence of that. Where'd you get that
from?
>> Well, again, because I usually when we
debate, you give you have a given,
right? [clears throat]
>> You give someone something. So I gave
you that what the Bible said was true.
>> You got this twisted.
>> You didn't give me anything. You made
>> I said that the Bible is true.
>> That was that was off you gave you.
>> That was off of you.
>> I didn't make any claims as argument cuz
you five things are true.
>> Yep. Because these these are the things
you named. So besides the bottom one. So
you named these things as if they were
facts that Jesus actually did. I asked
you where you got that from. You
mentioned the Bible. I didn't bring none
of this stuff up.
>> So, you didn't give me nothing. I let
you have the Bible in the beginning. But
now that we saw that according to the
Bible, you actually don't follow Jesus
at all. But now you're saying, "Oh,
that's why we don't believe in all the
Bible." Okay, fine. Bible is off the
freaking table. How do you know Jesus
did any of this?
>> You [clears throat] know what? Forget
prostration cuz Quran doesn't mention
it.
>> Peace greeting. Salam alalayikum or shal
what however you said it in Aramaic. Can
you show me where in the Quran where
Jesus gave the peace greeting? Salam
alalaykum.
>> Okay, let me see.
>> Mhm.
[snorts]
Uh
[sighs]
he said peace be upon me, not peace be
upon you.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> So where do you get this idea that Jesus
gave a peace greeting similar to
salamikum?
>> Again the Bible. [clears throat]
>> So it looks to me brother that
everything that you know about Jesus
when it comes to how he practiced his
religion and what he actually believed
really really it comes from the Bible
not the Quran. Is that right? Without
the Bible, you don't know anything about
him.
>> The the Bible that was written like by
the Christians.
>> Yeah. By his apostles.
>> Yeah. Um I I think I'm just like out of
my depth because I didn't really like I
got three things in my head and I didn't
really research beforehand.
>> Say, let me tell you something, brother.
>> One, for you to even say what you just
said shows your humility. you're you're
you have no problem admitting if like
you just said you're out of your depth
on something on a particular topic or if
you don't know something. I appreciate
that. I want you to know that I'm not
like I'm not here to blast you out or
anything like that. Okay? Like it may
seem like that with my energy, but we
just have a good time. You know, I like
I like doing this. It's fun. I like to
make this fun. But the importance is
truth. I want you to have the truth more
than anything, bro. The truth is is that
all of your information that you get
about how Jesus practices religion comes
from the same book that you reject. How
do you reconcile that? You can't as a
Muslim.
>> Well, uh I you well when I say that
because I was using the Bible cuz that's
what you follow. uh
you don't you don't believe me like you
don't you say that oh because if you use
the Bible then if then this is true but
it's it it can't be true and it's not
right
>> right that's your dilemma you have to
affirm the Bible in order to make the
claim that you made and when you do
affirm the Bible you're throwing Islam
under the bus because obviously uh is
the the Quran contradicts what the Bible
says if the Bible is true Quran is false
if the Bible is false, then the Quran is
still false because it says the Bible is
true. So either way you go,
>> it's a dilemma.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> My point is this.
>> Okay. How about the I guess well I also
mentioned that that he was cursed in the
Bible as well.
>> No, he wasn't cursed. He took on a curse
for us. He became a curse for us.
>> He became a curse. Yeah. So he is
cursed.
>> No, he became a curse and destroyed the
curse for us. Took by taking on
>> Say destroyed on sin.
>> Does it say he destroyed the curse?
Well, you you can you can disagree with
the theology all you want. My my point
is is that you do not believe what Jesus
believed. You don't follow Jesus. And if
you don't follow Jesus, then your
religion is false. Wouldn't you agree?
>> If I don't follow No.
>> If your if your religion is in
opposition to the religion of Jesus,
then your religion is false. Right.
>> Well, in what way is in opposition? that
he was crucified and that
>> first first answer the question
>> first answer the question this question
is very important say
>> well because we some information we do
get from the Bible okay but it differs
in the Quran that he was not
>> that's not my [clears throat] question
>> well yeah your question is uh if it goes
against Jesus it's false right if a
religion
>> yes goes against
>> your religion goes against the religion
of Jesus that religion is false right do
you [clears throat] agree with that
>> yeah well there well then if we're assum
assuming the religion of Jesus is from
the Bible.
>> Do you agree with that or not?
>> Well, no, cuz the religion of Jesus
isn't isn't from the Bible. They don't
believe that.
>> I didn't say that. I asked simply, if
your religion goes Let me ask you this.
Let's let's let's actually let's let's
break it down into minute things, man.
And and by the way, that is worth
writing down. You can still have a true
religion even if it goes against Jesus.
You going in the real? As I said, we
believe he is Muslim because he was a he
because Muslim means he was he submitted
to God.
>> I know you believe that. So, with that
being said, is the religion of Jesus the
truth?
>> Christianity. Christianity came.
>> I didn't bring up Christianity. I I need
you to hear
>> I I'm bringing it up because I'm trying
to say,
>> "Yeah, but talk to me. Don't talk to
somebody else that may be in your head.
Talk to me. I didn't bring up
Christianity. I didn't bring up Islam."
Does Jesus have the true religion? Yes,
sir.
>> The religion that he follows is Islam.
That's what we believe.
>> I know you believe it. I don't care.
>> Yeah.
>> My question is this.
>> So,
>> does Jesus have the true religion? Yes
or no?
>> If his true religion is Islam, then yes.
Yes. His
>> if his religion is then yes.
>> So, it's possible that Jesus has Okay.
So, is Jes is the religion of Jesus the
truth? Yes or no? I just need a yes or
no.
>> Yes. But
>> if you go against the religion of Jesus,
>> if your religion is against the religion
of Jesus,
>> is that religion a false religion? Yes
or no?
>> Again, [clears throat]
he his religion
>> struggling with this amazing.
>> So we can't
>> you're a Muslim.
>> We can't we can't go can't go against
Islam.
>> Thank you, bro. Thank you for making it
into the I kept you on long enough for
you to make it into the red book. You
can have a religion against Jesus.
>> Red book. I never said that.
>> Yes, you did. And still
>> okay then I said it wrong erroneously
>> be true s 123 where we at 2 hours and 48
so probably 2 hours and 45 maybe maybe
46 45 to 2 48. So what I'm doing is I'm
documenting the dumbest [clears throat]
and craziest things that Muslims say
throughout the year. And I never write
the same thing twice. I always write
something new. So you're the first
person to say this one. You're gonna
misrepresent what I said because I again
he was Muslim so no you can't go against
Islam.
>> I I don't have to misrepresent anything.
I just take what you say verbatim.
>> Okay. I then what I said was wrong. Did
I say that if we go against his
religion? Yeah. That we can go against
Jesus religion.
>> Okay. Good. Now this is what I'm asking
you now. Let's go ahead and let's
establish what the religion of Jesus is.
Where do we get that from? T you're
going to
>> don't ask me what I'm going to do. The
answers you have the chance to answer.
Where do we get the religion of Jesus
from? Like where do we find out
>> what Jesus's religion was and how he
practiced his religion? What he
believed? What he taught? Where do we go
to get that? Just be honest. I know
you're a Muslim, but just
>> the Old Testament.
>> The Old Testament. Fine. So, the Old
Testament is where we get the teaching
um and belief and practices of what
Jesus believed. Yeah. Well, not not
everything is right, though.
>> You see how you got from the Old
Testament?
>> And and and it's because I'm letting you
on this long for a reason
>> cuz you're never going to forget this.
You'll never forget this. You're going
to remember this moment. You're going to
remember this talking to me. You're
going to remember this moment. My dad
used to My dad told me told that to me
and my wife on our wedding day. Remember
this moment. I ain't forgot it yet
since. You're not going to forget this.
I I'm keeping you on this long forever.
Sorry guys. Sorry audience. I know that
you guys are probably tired of this cuz
he's playing games and stuff, but I I
want him to feel this. He has to feel
this. The fact that you have no answers
I'm glades.
>> What?
>> What? No. I'm I'm glad that I was shown
that I didn't do any research because
then next time I'll be able to, you
know, be prepared. No. Well, get get
actual quotes and biographies from that
we believe are true in Islam cuz
>> uh I was kind of confused about the
Sabbath day and the this like this whole
debate. I I just didn't know which like
which was which which thing we believe
is true and which thing we don't believe
is true.
>> Yeah. So just to be clear, my friend,
because we're the most important thing
in this conversation is for us to
establish the religion of Jesus. And so
you're agreeing
>> Yeah.
>> that we can get the religion of Jesus
from the Old Testament. Is that right?
>> To my knowledge right now. Yeah.
>> Okay. So what the Torah says, what the
prophets wrote, that's the religion of
Jesus. prophets like what Abraham was
>> like Zechariah, Ezekiel, Moses,
Jeremiah, Isaiah, Malachi, Zephaniah,
all these prophets. That's all the Old
Testament.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Let's go to the Torah. I'll start
I'll start with the Torah cuz that's the
beginning. The first five books of
Moses. Moses wrote the Torah. All right.
God gave the Torah to Moses. Let's see
what Moses Mo Moses taught. I'm in the
Arabic Bible right now. Let me get back
to Let me get back to English. Here we
go. This is Deuteronomy. This is the
fifth book of the Torah. It says, "Do
you thus repay the Lord, you foolish and
senseless people? Is he not your father
who created you, who made you and
established you?"
>> Wait, who's saying this?
>> I believe Moses is saying this. Let's
see in the beginning. Yeah. This is a
song of Moses.
>> Okay.
>> So, Moses is teaching that God is our
heavenly father like Jesus believed.
>> Okay.
>> We good so far?
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> All right. Does the Quran agree with
that?
>> No. So, we see that the Quran is not in
line with the belief of Jesus. Not just
Jesus, but also Moses and the prophets.
Isn't that
>> Well, uh then I guess I don't know like
where we get our biographies from in
Islam. And I need to find that about the
prophets.
>> I'll tell you where you get it from,
brother, and where your scholars get it
from. It comes from the Torah, from the
Bible, from the from the people of the
book. Matter of fact, watch watch what
the Quran says. The Quran answers all of
this. It answers all of this. Look,
watch. Um, this is my this is actually
my favorite verse of Have you ever seen
any of my videos before, bro? You know,
>> I've seen some debates.
>> Some debates before.
>> Yeah.
>> This is my favorite verse, man. The
Quran tells you what to do. Look, if
you're in doubt, if you got questions,
look what it tells you to do. So, if you
are in doubt, oh, Muhammad, about that
which we have revealed to you, then ask
those who have been reading the
scripture before you. The truth has
certainly come to you from your Lord. So
never be among the doubters. Now I'm not
saying that necessarily that Muhammad
actually did doubt. It's hypothetical if
he's doubting. Here's what he's he can
do. If you got questions about what
Allah is saying in the Quran, especially
regarding the prophets, Muhammad found
in the Bible, um the stories of the
prophets, Jesus, Moses, all them, then
ask those who have been reading the
scripture before you. You come to us.
That's where you get the biographies
from. This is how you learn about the
prophets, about Jesus,
>> about Israelites. the I the the problem
is like a lot of these the gospels
aren't written by they're written by man
>> it's talking about the injil it's not
talking about the Bible
>> you would agree the Quran was written by
man right
>> no but wait a second when the Quran
talks about the scripture it's the injil
which we believe was revealed to Isa as
one book
>> and you agree that
>> you agree the Quran was also written by
men right Like what you mean a man
authored the Quran?
>> Not necessarily authored but wrote it.
>> Well, it was written down. Yes.
>> Okay. By men
>> by people.
>> Yeah. Okay. Same with the angel. The
Quran says the angel was written.
[clears throat]
>> It says that it was revealed.
>> It was revealed to Jesus.
>> I understand. It was revealed to Jesus
and then later written down. Okay.
[clears throat] Look, let me show you.
You're right that it says that Allah
gave the angel to Jesus and we gave him
the book. We gave the the angel
specifically. But now let me show you
this. The Quran also says that the angel
was written down. Okay. 757. And you
read Arabic too. So that would be better
for us cuz you can see that it says
maktuben which means written right. Look
it says let me um get back to the
English again. All right. Okay. Chapter
7 verse 157. Say those who follow the
messenger the prophet who can neither
read nor write. I'm skipping the
brackets because that's not like part of
the text. Whom they find written with
them in the Torah and the In the Gospel.
It's written and
>> what is this?
>> This is chapter 7 verse 157. What's the
only thing we do around here y'all?
That's it. We just read around here.
Ain't that
>> ain't it? Just pay my Jizzy. God bless
brother. We just read, man. That's it.
It says that, right? Can you confirm it
says that for me that it says that they
have the Torah and the Gospel written
with them?
>> I believe. Okay. I believe it's shocking
about that the Torah and the Gospel
contain prophecies.
>> Yes.
>> Of [snorts]
coming prophet.
>> Yeah.
>> And it says that they're written down in
them, right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Written by Allah.
>> No.
>> Or or revealed by Allah. And it's Torah.
>> I got you. revealed by Allah, written by
men. Right.
>> Yeah. I I don't get your point. Like the
Bible do agree.
>> I'm saying that the gospels
>> I got you were offered.
>> Okay.
>> They weren't revealed.
>> Agree that the Torah and the Gospel were
written down.
>> Yeah. They were re They weren't
revealed.
>> I didn't ask about revealed. We already
got past that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I'm saying if you follow
something that wasn't revealed by God,
then it's just and it's written by
disciples.
>> Uh-huh.
>> Yeah. Then it's it's not a it's not part
of the religion.
>> Okay. So, just to be clear, hold on, no,
no, hold on. If something is revealed by
God, but then written down by disciples
or apostles or companions, then
therefore what's written down is not
part of the religion.
>> No, I didn't say that.
>> Okay. Well, that's what I'm asking.
Well, if the disciples authored and they
had inconsistencies between author, it's
revealed by God. Obviously, the angels
revealed by God.
>> No, the gospel the gospels has different
accounts of the same story.
>> Say, I need you to focus, please.
>> That's that's not a that's not
revelation.
>> Is the end written down? Yes or no?
>> Well, yes, it was written
>> by who? God or men?
>> Well, it it didn't come as a book. It
didn't like
>> Awesome. So, who wrote it
>> come down as a book? Were they written
by Allah or men?
>> Holy yes, men.
>> Thank you. Which men?
>> It's like the Quran.
>> Awesome. Which men?
>> Let me let me check. I don't know.
>> You don't know which men? I can give you
a hot clue. [clears throat]
>> The Okay.
>> Who? Say it. Say it, brother. It's right
in your face.
>> I don't see an answer.
>> Huh?
>> Is it Hali [clears throat] and Khan?
What? What is your
>> No, that's a that's a that's a
commentary. All right. Not a commentary.
That's
>> okay. How is it right in my face?
>> I thought you were looking at it cuz you
It sound like you looked it up. Sorry.
Did you look it up?
>> I was trying.
>> Who wrote the gospel? Have you ever read
uh Ibnshak, the life of the prophet?
>> Ishach.
Ibn Ishach. Have you ever read his uh
his safarat before? The life of the
prophet.
>> Oh, Sirat.
>> Sirat. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I sorry your pronunciation was
confusing me, but
>> Sorry, man. I I'm an English.
>> Yeah. Uh, no I haven't.
>> Well, in his life of the prophet, he
narrates from Muhammad that John wrote
the gospel of Jesus as Jesus told it to
him. Even your scholars like look these
commentators like I told you I don't
read the brackets cuz it's not part of
the original text. But even in look in
brackets what they put Torah Deuteronomy
18:15 in Gospel John 14:16 they're
quoting the Bible.
>> Yeah. So, are you saying that because
they're quoting the Bible, they it's
true? Yes. The Bible is true.
>> The Quran points to the Bible. So, it's
true for you.
>> Okay.
>> So, look, man.
>> Well,
>> uh what's it called? I I have No, I I
just realized I have uh a college class
online in a in a bit.
>> Yeah, don't be late. So, I I do have to
go, but thanks thanks for the
opportunity because then that will help
me research more about this.
>> Yes, you can come back next You can come
back next time, man. Don't be a
stranger.
>> Yeah. Have a good night. YouTube, bro.